[Musique]
oui
m
[Musique]
dieu
c'est
[Musique]
je vais mieux
il n'y a rien de tel qu'une bonne année
et un bon déjeuner pour vous remettre
[Musique]
beaucoup coup je suis le coucou avec
nous tu es sedan sécurité coucou coucou
vient la maison il ya un bon dîner au
que vous êtes gentils mes amis que cela
me fait du bien
[Musique]
fallou blanchette vita on dirait qu'elle
a trouvé quelque chose et puis quand
as-tu ce bracelet ont été trouvés
cachottière je vais s'il a perdu c'est
moi qui me touche où il est joli non la
pauvre madame pic on accuse le pam a
devancé n'y a non non on n'a rien vu la
politique de non intervention au cher
que vous êtes savons que vous parlez
bien
parfaitement nous sommes pour la
non-intervention que ce passe-t-il
il règne une excitation anormal par ici
il faut voir ça de près mais c'est le
bracelet de suzy oro au me faire ça à
moi me laisser accusé d'un vol dont vous
ne saviez innocente
on le savait rien on vient de
l'apprendre
vous êtes de ville et menteuse ou le
saviez fort bien mais ça ne va pas se
passer comme ça et toi sale petite
gamine
les six accusés une honorable mère de
famille à ta place
moi qui n'ai jamais rien pris enfin très
rarement vilaine vilaine petite volaille
et madame l'api jure de se venger
mais avant tout il faut rendre le
bracelet et en montrant bien que c'est
elle madame l'api injustement accusés
qui l'a retrouvé mais comment s'y
prendre
elle plonge vers blanchatte se venge
saisi le bracelet s'envole hésite un
moment et le laisse tomber devant la
porte du fermier puis elle attend nous
aussi mes petits amis
nous allons attendre le prochain épisode
pour la suite des événements
[Musique]
il